do you see all technology in that way so
basically technology helps us appreciate
the more sort of
technology-free aspect of life
well
media technology
you know i mean i i you can stretch that
i mean you can
let me say i could definitely play
mcluhan and turn this into a general
theory it's totally doable the program
you just described is totally doable
um in fact i will psychically predict
that if you did the research you could
find 20 phd theses that do that already
yeah i don't i don't know but they might
exist but um i i don't know how much
value there is in pushing
a particular
idea that far
claiming that reality isn't a computer
in some sense seems incoherent to me
because we have we can program it we
have technology it has it seems to obey
physical laws what more do you want from
it to be a computer i mean it's a
computer of some kind we don't know
exactly what kind we might not know how
to think about it we're working on it
but
uh sorry to interrupt but you're
absolutely right like that's my
fascination with the ai as well
is it uh helps in the case of ai
i see is as a set of techniques that
help us understand ourselves understand
us humans in the same way virtual
reality
and you're putting it brilliantly which
it's a it's a way to help us understand
reality
sure appreciate and open our eyes more
richly to reality
that's that's certainly how i see it and
i i wish people who become incredibly
fascinated who go down the rabbit hole
of uh the different fascinations with
whether we're in a simulation or not or
you know that there's a whole world of
variations on that um
i wish they'd step back and think about
their own motivations and exactly what
they mean you know what and and i think
the danger with these things
is
um
so if you say is the universe some kind
of computer broadly it has to be because
it's not coherent to say the the uh that
it isn't on the other hand to say that
that means you know anything about what
kind of computer
that's something very different and the
same thing is true for the brain the
same thing is true for
anything where you might use
computational metaphors like we have to
have a bit of modesty about where we
stand and the problem i have with these
framings of computation as these
ultimate cosmic questions is that it has
a way of getting people to pretend they
know more than they do
you